because so planets aren't really my
thing I have to say but I realized I do
actually know one sort of slightly
interesting thing from a physicists
point of view about Jupiter which is
actually the first measurement of the
speed of light was actually done using
Jupiter
today I've chosen to talk about the
planet Jupiter which i think is a
fascinating planet because it's the most
massive planet in our solar system by
far it's so massive that if you take all
of the other planets and add them up
Jupiter is still two-and-a-half times
more massive than the rest of the
planets so it's a big one
I completely forgotten I had a cardboard
you could do it there I'll go grab it
yes it's not quite right because if you
look at it a little more closely you'll
find it's not terribly spherical it's
not no but it's a little hard to make a
spherical thing out of a piece of paper
Jupiter was first detected first seen
through a telescope by Galileo in 1610
and he actually found four dots around
it is what he saw and so he observed
them for a while and he saw that the
position of the dots moved if in fact it
was the moons of Jupiter that really got
Galileo into trouble with the church
because he started pointing out that not
everything rotates around the earth the
earth isn't the center of everything
Jupiter actually has things rotating
around it and that's what caused all the
trouble and we have since called these
four moons the the Galilean moons and
their I always remember him with I eat
green carrots
yo Europa Ganymede and Callisto that's
the order that they are from from
Jupiter but one of the things that
Galileo realized is you could actually
use those moons as a clock you could
actually watch them orbiting around and
when they you know just like the hands
over clock where they are in their orbit
tells you the time basically and so he
actually proposed it to the king of
Spain and lots of work was done on it
turns out to be a pain to do because you
have to be able to observe Jupiter and
see the moons and measure their
positions very accurately so it wasn't
terribly useful for that but nonetheless
a whole load of measurements were made
of the positions of the moons of Jupiter
and people found that it did indeed work
as a very accurate clock except that
sometimes it seemed to run a bit slow
and sometimes it seemed to run a bit far
sometimes it seemed to be a bit behind
where you're expecting it to be
sometimes you seem to be it seemed to be
a bit ahead and in fact it was Cassini
the guy who found the gaps in the rings
of Saturn and lots of other astronomical
things who first figured out the
explanation for this which is that he
figured out the reason for this was
because of the light that was showing us
what was going on so the light was
traveling to us from Jupiter was taking
a finite amount of time to get to us and
so when Jupiter is a long way away from
us in the solar system on its orbit then
the light takes that bit
longer and so we see the clock a bit
further in the past when you put us
quite close to us we see it pretty much
as it is now and therefore there isn't
that time delay and so it was realized
you could actually use this to measure
the speed of light by looking at what
these time delays were at different
times you could see how long it was
actually taking the light to get to us
if you knew how far away Jupiter was you
could use all that to figure out the
speed of light since the 1600s again in
1660 ish someone looked at Jupiter with
the most powerful telescope at the time
and found a dot on it which is what
we've come to call the Great Red Spot
which is a massive storm on Jupiter so
big that you could actually fit two
Earth's inside of this storm and it's
lasted for over 300 years now the planet
has a lot of gas it's a gas giant so
it's mostly hydrogen and there's some
helium and a couple other things mixed
in there but it's all gas is far down
hundreds of miles as we've been able to
probe into the surface and this gas is
moving around quite quickly Jupiter
rotates on its axis very quickly in 10
hours which for such a huge planet is
really fast so what that causes is that
all the gas on the surface sort of
separates into layers so if you look at
Jupiter at an image you see almost
stripes horizontally along the planet
and they are dark and they're bright so
Jupiter has some well-known moons
Ganymede is one moon and it's the
biggest moon in the entire solar system
it's actually bigger than mercury so
that one's exciting it's got craters on
it so EO is the closest moon and it's a
very big moon and since it's so close to
Jupiter it interacts with it strongly
gravitationally and with its magnetic
field and so the result of that is a lot
of volcanic activities so volcanoes
erupted all the time there's a lot of
sulfur not much chance for life or
anything there with as much activity as
it has going on now but Europa on the
other hand is actually a place in our
solar system where we could potentially
have life now the surface is very smooth
it's a big thick layer of I
then we see cracks along the surface in
the ice but the ice is so thick it's
maybe 50 to 100 miles thick and
potentially underneath there there could
be liquid oceans with things growing I
mean we don't really know it's not
likely but we do have life-forms at in
the depths of the ocean near volcanoes
on earth so there could potentially be
something there in 1994 we found the
first comet orbiting around something
other than the Sun so this comment was
called shoemaker-levy 9 and it was found
to be orbiting around Jupiter and it has
very elliptical very long orbit and so
and one of the passes pretty close to
after we detected it it went very close
to Jupiter and so it was predicted that
it was going to actually run into
Jupiter and so this was not only the
first comment that we had ever found
orbiting and something other than the
Sun but it was potentially going to
crash in to Jupiter so it would be the
first time we'd ever see something like
that the first point of contact when it
crashed into the southern part of
Jupiter was on the other side of us so
we couldn't see it but we had spacecraft
that actually monitored that impact and
then it rotated so quickly
that within an hour - we could actually
see the sights of the impact so we
weren't sure what was going to happen we
didn't know if there's a surface
somewhere down in the depths of Jupiter
that we could see or if these pieces
would just be completely engulfed by the
atmosphere so we couldn't see anything
but we did end up seeing some reactions
we saw some really dark spots forming
there were a successive period of 5 days
where these pieces hit Jupiter and you
could see these big dark clouds forming
and they just slowly faded over time so
that was a pretty exciting thing when I
was when I was young and I was just
thinking about my interest in astronomy
that was one of the things that I
remember happening in real time and it
was just fantastically exciting